Problem 36.
Use the diagram below
to answer the
question that follows.
All right.
There's my diagram.
A gift box has dimensions
x by y by z.
A decorative ribbon is wrapped
across the diagonals of the
box, as shown above.
Which of the following
expressions represents the
approximate total length
of the ribbon?
All right.
So let's just measure
this ribbon.
So what's this length,
right here?
What's that length,
right there?
Well if we draw that side of the
box, the height is z, and
the depth is y.
And the ribbon goes from the
bottom left to the top right.
So we can use the Pythagorean
theorem right here, right?
Because if this height is
z, then this height,
right here, is z.
So this is a right triangle, and
so we can figure out the
hypotenuse using the Pythagorean
theorem.
So we could say that the length,
right here, the length
squared-- maybe I'll write it
like that-- the length squared
is equal to y squared
plus z squared.
Or the length is equal to
the square root of y
squared plus z squared.
That's this length right here.
Now, we could use that exact
same argument on this side of
the box, over here.
You can imagine just, if we were
to face it-- well, if you
were to just turn it around,
it would look
exactly like this.
Or if you were to look at it
from the inside of the box, it
would look like this.
It looks like this is
the back of it.
So if we're looking at it
from this direction,
it looks like this.
The height is z.
The base is y.
And so we just have
the hypotenuse.
y squared plus z squared is
going to be equal to the
length squared.
Or the length is equal to y
squared plus the square root
of y squared, plus z squared.
So that's this length
and that length.
So, so far, if we just wanted to
add up just that length and
that length, we're going to
have 2 times each of them.
So 2 times the square of y
squared, plus z squared.
That's the two red parts
of the ribbon.
Now, what is this length
right here?
Well, same argument.
If I were to just draw the base
of this rectangle, the
depth is y, the width is x,
and the ribbon just goes
across it like that.
So if we call this the length,
l, of this blue part, you have
l squared is equal to x squared
plus y squared, or l
is equal to the square root of
x squared plus y squared.
That's this length,
right there.
And then this length over here
might not look the same,
because of the way that the
perspective works, but it's
the exact same thing.
It's the exact same thing.
If this is x, this depth is y.
If you were look at the box from
the top, this length is
x, the depth is y, the top
ribbon looks like that.
So x squared plus y squared
is going to be
equal to that thing.
So this length is also
the square root of x
squared plus y squared.
So that's the square root of
x squared plus y squared.
This is the square root of
So in the total length of the
ribbon, we're going to have
two of them.
Plus 2 times the square root of
x squared plus y squared.
So the total length of the
ribbon: 2 times the square
root of x squared, plus y
squared, plus 2 times the
square root of y squared,
plus z squared.
Let's see, that looks
like choice C.
They just factored the 2 out,
so it's 2 times everything.
Square root of x squared plus
y squared, plus the square
root of y squared
plus z squared.
Right over there.
Next problem.
Problem 37.
Use the graph below to answer
the question that follows.
All right.
We have this little drawing
of a hand pointing up.
If the image of a pointing hand
in the graph above is
rotated 180 degrees about the
origin, and then reflected
across the x-axis, which of the
following graphs will result?
So let's do it step by step.
If you rotate it 180 degrees,
you're rotating it like this.
Around the x-axis, you're
rotating it like that.
So for example, this square--
we could draw it, maybe I'll
do it in a lighter color-- this
right here, this part of
the hand is going to rotate it
all the way down, so it's
going to look like that,
right there, if I
were to shade it in.
And then the hand-- this part,
right here, is going to be
rotated all the way
down like this.
So the hand's going to look
something like this.
That's the thumb part.
And then you're going to have
the finger coming out like
this, the finger part, the
finger pointing up.
And then you're going to
have the other fingers.
So the hand's going to look
something like that when you
rotate it 180 degrees.
I just rotated around
the origin.
Now, the second part
is that then,
reflected across the x-axis.
So then if we reflect this
across the x-axis, it's going
to look like this.
It's going to look something
like that, like right there.
So that should be our answer.
So which of the choices
looks like that?
Looks like choice C.
Choice C looks exactly
what we drew up here.
Well, the finger is closer to
the vertical axis than, I
guess, the pinky is in either
case, because we rotated
around and then we flipped.
And that is choice C.
Next question.
Problem 38.
Which of the following
nets can be folded to
form a square pyramid?
So a square pyramid-- this is
all, you're going to get some
visualization problem-- a
square pyramid is just a
pyramid that has a square
as its base, like
the pyramids in Egypt.
So it has a square
as its base.
So that's the square base.
Let's see if I can
construct one.
If I were to fold this guy up,
and then this guy up, then can
this guy be the other
side of the pyramid?
No, because if I fold this
guy up like this.
So let's say, imagine,
let's fold them up.
And so I have a pyramid,
so this guy
gets folded like that.
And then this guy over
here, can he fold in?
He's going to fold straight
down and fill that up.
So this guy, right here, can
fill that right there.
Let me use some colors.
And then if this guy,
when I fold it,
will fill right there.
And then when I-- and
then this flap
won't fill in the blank.
This flap won't go where
it's supposed to.
This flap will just re-cover
this flap again.
So choice A is not the
correct choice.
Let's see choice B.
So if I flip this over,
that flap is just
going to go right there.
So that flap is going
to go right there.
And then, let's say, this
flap is going to
go over right there.
And then this flap, this flap
right here, let's see, if this
slap, this side right there is
going to be that side, so this
flap is going to go right over
on this side, just like that.
And then this last flap--
remember this edge is that
edge, right there.
So this last flap will
just fill in the
blank, right there.
So it looks like B works--
will actually form a
rectangular or a
square pyramid.
Let's see if these other ones
work, before I rule them out.
So this flap over here, this
top flap, when you flip it
over, is going to-- you could
imagine looking at the pyramid
from the top-- and then this
edge, over here-- let me do it
in pink-- this edge over here
would flip down and
fill up that edge.
But then this edge, right here,
will just, when you fold
this, will just go on top
of that same edge again.
And then this over here, will
just go over on top of this
edge, again.
So we're only getting 1/2
the pyramid, so that's
not going to work.
This one.
You flip this one over.
It's going to look like that.
Imagine looking at the
pyramid from above.
Then you flip this one over.
It's going to look-- let me
switch colors-- it's going to
look like this, this
part right here.
And then this piece-- let me do
it in purple-- this piece
right here, because this edge
is going to be this edge, is
going to fill that
right there.
But that's exactly where
this piece would go
when you flip it.
So we're going to have an empty
space right there, so
that also doesn't work.
So B is our answer.
Next problem.
Use the figure below to answer
the question that follows.
OK, they give us a
little triangle.
If equilateral triangle ABC--
well, equilateral tells us
that all of the slides are
equal-- represents one of two
congruent halves-- congruent
means completely sides and
angles are the same-- congruent
halves of a figure
that has AB as a line
of symmetry.
So AB is a line of symmetry.
And this is 1/2 the figure.
So the rest of the figure is
going to look like this.
So the line of symmetry, so
you'd literally just-- the
line of symmetry is going
to look like that.
It's going to look like that,
and that length is equal to
that length, is equal
that length, is
equal to that length.
So all four sides
are the same.
Then the entire figure
is, well, all four
sides are the same.
It's a little bit skewed,
so it can't be a square.
It's going to be a rhombus.
Problem 40.
Use the diagram below to answer
the question-- well, we
know how to do that.
Three straight lines
intersect to form a
triangle, as shown above.
What is the measure
of angle x?
Well here, we just use a couple
of our angle rules.
If you watched any of my videos
in the past, it's what
I call the angle game.
Let's play the angle game.
We have 60 degrees here.
This is opposite to the 60.
It's going to be the same angle,
so that is also going
to be 60 degrees, right there.
This is 115 degrees.
It is going to be supplementary
to this angle,
right here, which means
that this angle plus
115 is equal to 180.
So if we call this x, x plus
Subtract 115 from both sides.
x is equal to--
80 minus 15 is what?
80 minus 10 is 70.
70 minus 5 is 65.
So this angle right here
is 65 degrees.
And this angle-- let's call that
y-- y plus 65 plus 60.
And I don't want you to confuse
this x with that x.
I probably should've called that
some other number, but
I'm just saying 65 plus 175 is
going to be equal to 180.
That's how I got the 65.
They're supplementary.
And now let's figure out what
this angle y over here is.
y plus 60, plus 65 has to be
equal to 180 because they form
a triangle.
The angles in a triangle
add up to 180.
So y plus-- add these
two together--
125 is equal to 180.
y is equal to 180 minus 125.
80 minus 25 is what?
55.
So y is equal to 55 degrees.
We're not quite done.
y is equal to 55 degrees.
Now, x is supplementary to y.
So you say x plus 55 is
equal to 180 degrees.
Well, we already know what
plus 55 is equal to 180.
125.
So we say x is equal to 180
minus 55, which is equal to
125 degrees, which is choice
C, right there.